الول ستريت جورنال اهتمت بزياره بلينكن
الى الشرق الاوسط قائله انها تاتي بينما
تزداد وتيره الهجمات خارج نطاق الحرب في
غزه وتذكر الصحيفه ان بايدن ارسل واحدا من
اكثر مستشاريه بالبيت الابيض موثوقيه
لاحتواء الاخطاء التي قد تشعل حريقا لا
يمكن التنبؤ بعواقبه في
المنطقه صحيفه واشنطن بوست نشرت لاشان
ثارور يقول ان دعوات التطهير العرقي في
غزه داخل اسرائيل تتزايد لكنها لا تبدو
منسجمه مع رؤيه المؤسسات الامنيه وربما لن
تنعكس في موقف الحكومه الرسمي وينقل
الكاتب عن مصدر مطلع على محادثات الحكومه
قوله انهم يدركون جيدا انه لا وجود
لمستقبل في غزه دون سكان
غزه كتبت صحيفه لوفيجارو ان حديث رئيس
الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع السوداني عن
رغبته في رؤيه القوات الاجنبيه تغادر
البلاد بعد استهداف قيادين بالحشد الشعبي
بضربه امريكيه ياتي هذه المره في سياق
يتاثر فيه العراق بتداعيات الحرب بين
اسرائيل وحماس وتصاعد التوترات في
المنطقه تناول تقرير لصحيفه نيويورك تايمز
تحذيرات منظمه اسرائيليه مناهضه لسياسه
الاستيطان من ان بؤرا جديده استحدثت في
الضفه الغربيه بينما تستمر الحرب في غزه
يعتبر التقرير ان هذه الانشطه ومختلف
اشكال عنف المستوطنين تفاقم التوترات في
الضفه الغربيه خصوصا في وقت تكثف فيه
القوات الاسرائيليه دهم واعتقال المزيد من
الفلسطينيين ينطلق تقرير في صحيفه
الفاينانشال تايمز من اعلان شركه عملاقه
للشحن اعاده توجيه سفنها بعيدا عن البحر
الاحمر ويلاحظ ان الخطوه تاتي على الرغم
من الجهود التي تقودها الولايات المتحده
لتامين مسار سفن الشحن البحري بالمنطقه
واشار التقرير الى تحذيرات خبراء من ان
تابعات اضطراب عمليات الشحن بدات
[موسيقى]
بالظهور